E
APPAREL SHOP AND WERE
AUTHENTICATED BY PEOPLE FAMILIAR
WITH THEM AND WITH THE
INVESTIGATION.
SO THIS IS A MASSIVE, MASSIVE
WIN FOR THE PEOPLE, I GUESS, WHO
WERE CENSORED, AND FIRST AMONG
THEM IS MIRANDA DEVINE, WHO WAS
CENSORED WHEN SHE TRIED TO TELL
THE TRUTH.
SHE IS A COLUMNIST FOR
"THE NEW YORK POST," WE ARE
HAPPY TO HAVE HER JOIN US
TONIGHT.
HOW DOES THIS FIELD HAVE BEEN
"NEW YORK TIMES" ADMIT THAT YOU
WERE RIGHT ALL ALONG?
>> IT'S KIND OF DELICIOUS TO SEE
THEM SORT OF SQUIRMING AROUND
TRYING TO ADMIT THE OBVIOUS, BUT
YOU KNOW, IF YOU'RE A READER OF
"THE NEW YORK POST" OR IF YOU
WILL ARE AT FOX NEWS, YOU KNEW
THIS 16 MONTHS AGO.
HE DIDN'T NEED THE GREAT
"NEW YORK TIMES" TO TELL YOU
THAT IT WAS TRUE AND AT THAT THE
EMAILS.
WE ALREADY DID THAT.
AND WE PUBLISHED TRUTH, THE
STORIES THAT WERE REAL AND HAVE
CONTINUED TO DO SO WITHOUT FEAR
OR FAVOR.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" READERS
HAVE BEEN KEPT IN THE DARK BY
THEIR NEWSPAPER, OR ORGAN OF
CHOICE, AND THAT WAS FOR
DELIBERATE REASONS.
IT WAS BECAUSE THEY WANTED
DONALD TRUMP TO LOSE THE 2020
ELECTION.
SO ALL JOURNALISTIC ETHICS AND
STANDARDS WENT OUT THE WINDOW
AND IT DOESN'T MATTER HOW YOU
TRY AND DRESS IT UP NOW AND
PRETEND THAT YOU JUST FOUND OUT.
EVEN IF YOU DIDN'T HAVE THE
LAPTOP, AS YOU KNOW, BECAUSE YOU
INTERVIEWED TONY AT THE TIME, HE
WAS A PATRIOT, A HERO, WHO STOOD
UP AGAINST HIS OWN INTERESTS TO
TELL THE WORLD THE TRUTH ABOUT
JOE BIDEN AND ABOUT HIS
INFLUENCE PEDDLING, THE WAY HE
ABUSED HIS POWER TO MAKE MONEY
FROM FOREIGN COUNTRIES AT THE
EXPENSE OF AMERICA'S NATIONAL
INTERESTS, WE ARE NOW REAPING
THE SPOILS OF THAT AND I THINK,
YOU KNOW, ULTIMATELY WHAT WE
NEED TO KNOW NOW THAT WE ARE ALL
IN THE SAME PAGE, NOW THAT WE
AGREE THAT REALITY IS REALITY,
WHAT DO WE DO NEXT, AND I THINK
THE NEXT STEP IS TO ACTUALLY
LOOK AT THE EVIDENCE OF
WRONGDOING BY THE PRESIDENT AND
HIS FAMILY, OBVIOUSLY, BUT HE'S
THE IMPORTANT ONE, THAT'S
CONTAINED IN THE LAPTOP, AND DO
SOMETHING ABOUT IT.
>> Tucker: AND THROW OUT THE
CENSORSHIP REGIME THAT BEGAN
THAT DAY WHEN THE CENSORED YOU.
THEY KNOCKED PARLOR OFF THE
INTERNET.
WE'VE NEVER REALLY RECOVERED
FROM THAT.
EVERYTHING WE SAY IS NO CENSORED
AND NO ONE SAYS ANYTHING ABOUT
IT.
>> YES.
AND ALSO THE 50 FORMER
INTELLIGENCE PEOPLE,
JOHN BRENNAN, FORMER RECENT HEAD
OF THE CIA, THAT WAS
LEON PANETTA, THAT WAS
JAMES CLAPPER AND MICHAEL
HAYDEN, THESE PEOPLE WHO NOW TO
THIS DAY APPEARING ON CNN AND
MSNBC AS ESTEEMED EXPERTS ON
RUSSIA AND UKRAINE, AND THOSE
PEOPLE SHOULD NEVER HOLD THEIR
HEADS UP IN PUBLIC AGAIN.
IT THEIR REPUTATIONS ARE
DESTROYED BY THE FACT THEY'VE
SIGNED THAT LETTER AND LIED
ABOUT THE LAPTOP AND SAID
WITHOUT LOOKING AT IT THAT IT
WAS RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION AND
THEY GOT JOE BIDEN OFF THE HOOK.
>> Tucker: YOU THINK OF ALL
THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN
DESTROYED FOR NOTHING, SOME
STUPID COMMENT, YOU KNOW, AND
THEN CRIMINALS WHO WALK FREE, A
LOT